Tom woods stands accused of many things
but laziness is not one of them
a historian and senior fellow at the
Ludwig von Mises Institute woods is the
author of a dozen books including the
politically incorrect guide to American
history he's written curricula for the
Ron Paul home school program he co-hosts
along with economist Robert Murphy the
weekly contra crouppen podcast which
critiques columns by the New York Times
Nobel laureate Paul Krugman and he posts
a new episode of the popular tom woods
show every day a champion of the
Austrian School of Economics and devotee
of Murray Rothbard he was he says a
moderate Republican happy to lavish
government spending on domestic programs
and launched bombs at evildoers abroad
it was the 1992 presidential campaign of
Pat Buchanan who was against the Gulf
War and other military adventures abroad
that began the transformation never one
to shy away from a social media scrap
Woods got into an epic Twitter feud last
summer with a leadership of the
libertarian party with one side calling
the Mises Institute a gateway drug to
white nationalism in the old right
while Woods and his allies mocked the
libertarian National Committee as a
bunch of social justice warriors then
something curious happened after the
lp's Mises [ __ ] has failed to dislodge
party chair Nicolas SAR war at this
year's National Convention Woods and his
friends redoubled their efforts to
influence the party from within i sat
down with Tom woods to talk about his
ideological journey his involvement with
the Libertarian Party his controversial
past associations with such entities as
the League of the south and his
assessment of President Donald Trump
among many other topics so the first
time that I saw you talk live was down
the street from the Libertarian Party
biannual every two years whatever that
word is National Convention down in New
Orleans you were talking at a Mises
caucus kind of party festival there down
the street and you said something that's
very interesting I want to read it for
the the folks at home we are not
primarily advocating a slightly
different public policy from other
people we're encouraging people to look
at the world in a refreshing new way so
yeah we won't get the 70 million votes
sort of a reference to the libertarian
party but maybe we get the 1 million
people who say I never looked at the
world the same way again talk to me
about what you mean by that and how it
informs your
work and also maybe your interest in the
Libertarian Party well I find that a lot
of times the political discussion we
have is extremely narrow and this is one
area where I agree with Noam Chomsky
where he talks about manufacturing
consent that you're allowed to have a
discussion that spans you know two and a
half inches so we talk about what form
of taxation is better or in foreign
policy its we could have sanctions that
we know will lead to starvation and
malnutrition or we could just have a
bombing campaign and that just seems
like too narrow of a scope and I'm
suggesting that libertarians have a
fresh new way to think about the world
because we actually ask do we need
institution X do we need institution Y
and if we do need these things do they
have to be provided the way they're
traditionally provided could we not
learn to interact with each other on a
purely voluntary basis is society itself
not in some way self ordering and
incidentally that's why I've taken a
great interest in economics I feel like
just the field of economics when you
understand it right shows you something
important about the way society is self
ordering it shows you something about
how social cooperation occurs
spontaneously that's not what we're
taught the model of society that we
learn in school is that somebody with a
bullhorn has to be barking out orders
and then everybody obeys and I think
there may be a more attractive way of
arranging society so some of this is
like it's a 35-yard line discussion
which is a perennial complaint about
Washington this these are the parameters
of acceptable adults discussion that's
happening right here is part of what
you're kind of saying or even kind of
living that what you want to do is find
and even emphasize the stuff that's over
there on the fire in the ten yard line
or whatever the metaphor is now the 85
yard line is is it - is it to look for
those things that are outside that means
to kind of almost kind of shock people's
sensibilities and saying hang on a
second here what's going on well exactly
it would be something like when people
are arguing should there be transgender
equality in the military I want to take
it and make a meta question out of that
and say who wants to serve in the US
military these days when you know
perfectly well that basically none of it
has to do with defending you and me it
has to do with going and attacking
people you and I as ordinary
we'll have no quarrel with so it seems
misplaced to be worried about who gets
to serve in it to the country I said no
no this is that you're thinking about
things all the wrong way so for me that
by the way was the biggest stumbling
block to becoming a libertarian because
I grew up as a heaven help me a moderate
Republican which meant I was bad on
every issue you could think of I
believed in a lot of social spending I
believed in a hawkish foreign policy
I had conventional views on everything I
saluted the I was very flag II all that
stuff and now I look back on that and it
all just looks so cultish and and and
just awful and so I tend to go for
especially when I'm trying to reach
people who used to be like me I go for
those areas that I know we're stumbling
blocks for me like foreign policy now I
used to think you got to be some kind of
an unpatriotic commie if you don't agree
with US foreign policy and I I just hit
them on that I remind them what is it
that you guys say you believe it you
believe in absolute moral principles you
believe in stability you believe in
prudence these are not words I would use
to describe u.s. foreign policy
certainly since 2001 or two and that
does sometimes get them to think in fact
there was one of my favorite moments of
my whole speaking career was I was out
in Los Angeles speaking to a very mixed
crowd there were plenty of veterans in
the crowd and not veterans who were
having second thoughts but veterans who
had their Operation Desert Storm hats on
and it came time in my remarks where I
was going to say something about foreign
policy and I was second-guessing myself
I thought wow this might not really go
over well here but then I imagined any
of my heroes would they say to
themselves oh this crowd isn't ready for
this I thought no no I spent the whole
rest of the talk building up capital
with them and I said to them you're
better than this I said these sanctions
on the Iraqis have caused so much human
suffering and nobody cares about that
and yet these people their blood is as
red as yours or mine
I mean conservatives you've got to be
better than this how can you be swept
you of all people be swept up in this
and I got a standing ovation anyway what
changed your mind but knocked you out of
that out of this this John Kasich
sounding well you know Republican a lot
of people the
the younger folks so for them they say
well I supported the war in Iraq in 2003
and then I had second thoughts but for
me the war in Iraq that I grew up with
was the war in 1991 and I was 1990 as a
freshman in college and I knew full well
we had to get rid of Saddam whom I had
never heard of three months earlier but
I knew we had to get rid of him and then
as I watched that unfold and you know we
hear these stories of Iraqis being
incinerated you know with some kind of
an agent that just burns them alive in
the in the desert and and we're having
these Bob Hope specials and tying yellow
ribbons everywhere but there was a part
of me that thought well this is a great
human tragedy for those people and I
know it's one thing to say we feel sorry
about women and children who died but
you're not allowed to feel sympathy for
the people the the soldiers but I
thought I have no quarrel with any of
these soldiers I bet a lot of them are
there against their will their you know
a lot of them are like kids like ours
who just feel like they have no other
options that go into the military plus
they were people's husbands and fathers
and now these people are widows and
orphans and I thought I just can't
imagine having a Bob Hope special and a
big parade for this I felt very
uncomfortable about I felt sick about it
so I went in and I saw my European
history professor who at that time was
Charles Mayer his wife Pauline Mayer at
MIT died of a couple years ago I think
and and I knew he was for the war even
though he was a left-liberal
and I want to know what helped me
understand why this is okay because I I
couldn't believe that it could be wrong
I couldn't imagine the US government
could be wrong
help me believe and the best he could do
is he said well there was a cover story
in the New Republic that I ought to read
and that made a good liberal defense of
the war so I went I read that and that
kind of held me over but then when I
came in contact with people cuz I was
never gonna be on the left but that I
knew but when I found that there were
people who were not on the Left who also
thought these wars were rackets that
started to get my attention so I've
always felt like I want to be that guy
for other people so I one of the things
that was surprised about in senior
speech was that you like I I should say
supported initially the war in
Afghanistan after after 9/11 I curious
whether you look back at that
and whether I look back at that but
you're the one being interviewed here as
a mistake to have support yeah see I am
um I actually don't think I did so yeah
I thought I heard that in it ya know for
me it would be more I would favor some
kind of Ron Paul style targeted market
reprisals yeah that kind of thing I
would favor that because I think when
you and I were interviewed with Michael
malice he brought up for me that Ron
Paul had voted for the authorization
tree first but uh but III but the thing
and here's the thing when he by doing
that we were talking later about whether
that gave him extra credibility during
the debates because of if he had voted
against it it would have been just him
and Barbara Lee and and I felt like the
I could see strategically why he might
have made that choice to vote for that
because the Republicans would have eaten
him alive but on the other hand they ate
him alive anyway so much it really
mattered and but he managed to I mean
that was the moment that that was the
thing that got him he asked you a
question I asked Rand Paul five years
ago and he slipped out of it because
he's a politician but looking back at
now where you were at today looking back
at all of the post-world War two US
military conflicts would you support any
of wow you know I guess at this point I
believe or not I would say I wouldn't
yeah I know that sounds unbelievable and
crazy but I I just wouldn't the Vietnam
War is of course for a lot of people an
easy one but for me that was actually
hard because as I was growing up as I
was in high school again I felt like
I've got to learn how to defend the US
government come what may so I read
Richard Nixon's book no more Viet Nam's
by which he means no more going in and
not kicking the crap out of everybody
and I read that and it's a really really
powerful polemic in favor of the war and
that satisfied me okay
all you people are liberal commies for
not supporting the Vietnam War but then
you look back on I mean not you don't
even have to talk about the the
destruction and the loss of life among
people who lived there but also just
think about from the point of view of
people who favored that war how did it
turn out I mean it tore American Society
of parts of the Conservatives who
favored the war what they got at home
was a total social revolution exact
opposite when a the
wanted and then okay many many Americans
died then as there is even after all the
trillions of dollars and all who ever
know whoever knows an American in money
today how much it was but it was a loss
anyway and yet even though it was a loss
what strategic problem did it wind up
posing the US was still in the same
position it was before it was everything
was fine and now we have a you know
increasingly good relationship with
Vietnam so it was unnecessary it was so
I actually raised this I had Pat
Buchanan on my show and I thought Dog
Gone I'm not gonna have Pat on and not
ask him about this he was part of that
White House the Nixon White House he was
helping to make some of those decisions
I said Pat this thing blew up in your
face in every conceivable way I mean it
there's nothing a conservative could
shear as a result of any of this and I I
almost got him to concede that it was
possible that I could be right about
that
and I thought that's as far as a guy who
was in that White House that is the
closest I'm gonna get to a victory it
was his kind of post Gulf War critique
post Cold War critique of u.s. foreign
policy part of your journey from someone
who was kind of a default supporter of
this and to it was because nobody could
claim that Pat Buchanan was a left
winger and so when Pat was saying this
war is all wrong I remember thinking
what's wrong with him why doesn't he get
it you know we're all supposed to cheer
the military I really didn't understand
it but then as the 1990s went on and
there were sanctions placed on Iraq on a
variety of different types of goods and
they were having really bad consequences
and Saddam was surviving fine through
them as we sort of all knew he would to
see that it was Pat Buchanan this right
winger who was saying this is a moral
outrage and we've got to lift these
sanctions and it's it and he's saying
this at a time when people like
Madeleine Albright weren't saying we
should raise the same lift the sanctions
a lot of people on the Left liberal
establishment weren't saying that but
Buchanan said it that made me think
maybe there is something wrong with this
left-right divide maybe it doesn't
explain everything because I would
expect Noam Chomsky to say lift the
sanctions
I wouldn't expect Pat Buchanan so in a
way he was for me what Ron Paul became
for a lot of other people he was the
permission slip to question foreign
policy it's like it's okay you can still
be an American
good standing and you can you don't have
to feel like you're noam chomsky you can
just be you and just believe there's
something morally wrong here and speak
out about it you reference Ron Paul I
see you as kind of maybe you don't but
it's someone who sort of keeps the flame
of the Ron Paul movie I take that as a
cover-up or you know certainly talk
about him a lot yeah when I when I saw
you talk you said something that I've
found curious in New Orleans and
libertarians paradoxically need a leader
the way that you put it is most people
change or adopt ideology is not because
they're getting led by some stuffed
shirt but because they're jolted by an
articulate true believer so man I
thought we're all like individualist
well and the thing is we are but that's
precisely why without somebody to rally
to and I don't mean a leader who tells
you what to think or orders you to do
things but a rallying point now Ron Paul
was a rallying point and I think a lot
of us were concerned that when that
rallying point goes away do we all just
spin spin out and go our separate ways I
don't mind going our separate ways but I
don't like being in hostile camps where
there was a little bit of that among
libertarians but we were so interested
in what Ron Paul was doing and so
interested in how big the response was
at least compared to what we expected it
to be then I think it muted some of our
internal criticisms of each other I mean
I made some I look sometimes at my
Facebook friend list and I'd say boy I
remember when I was friends with that
guy in these days and I still want to be
friends with these for these folks but
but without that center of gravity some
people flew off this way some people
flew it this way and then it became this
is my group this is my clique of people
and I'm gonna defend them come what may
and then that I guess what I was talking
about it in New Orleans was that I miss
those days when we just said yeah we've
got our differences but man this is an
exciting moment that none of us thought
we would live through and we don't know
where it's going but we're gonna ride
this thing as long as we can I agree
with you about the excitement at the
moment I'm more reticence about the idea
of adhering behind one person seems to
me that that you always run the risk of
a cult or
analogy anywhere that is true Rampal
here and back in the 60s or whenever
that that's that's also a dangerous but
it's a but the fact is that without him
in public life and he has a podcast and
as is his daily show show the ron paul
liberty report but but without him in
public life i don't think it's a
coincidence that libertarians have
scattered a lot more since then so yeah
I agree I don't want a cult of
personality either I mean I was just
telling you before we went on about the
cult of personality around John Paul the
second was very bad for the Catholic
Church and the repercussions are still
there so I don't want that but what was
what was great about now it's gonna
sound like I'm going into that anyway
was great about Ron was that he would be
fearless in taking certain political
positions regardless of whether they
were gonna hurt him or help him he would
just say but this is what my philosophy
leads me to believe but then also on a
personal level I mean the guy was you
know he would do pro bono medical work
for poor people he was just a sweet
person and that guy who used whom you
saw on the screen when you meet him in
person he's just the same grandfatherly
kindly man who when he gets criticized
or smeared or attacked it just rolls
right I just doesn't mind I'm the total
opposite of that oh really
yeah no he's not I figure that are not
obvious so what are your designs with
the Libertarian Party I you're you are
now a sustaining member or whatever that
means
yeah of the party there is a Mises
caucus which isn't necessarily
affiliated with but the Mises Institute
but right certainly they've y'all like
each other here what
what are your designs on this do you
want to be the Ron Paul of the
libertarian party oh no no no I don't
some people want me to but I don't think
I want to do that but it just occurred
to me one day that there were they're
all in this there's a parallel I draw I
think about Ron Paul himself I mean he
was in his 70s in both of these
campaigns and he's out there campaigning
like crazy and for a guy who I mean he's
in we all know very good physical
condition but he sleeps very poorly in
hotels so he's flying around very little
sleep and he's doing all this stuff
there would be these anarchist
libertarians whom I consider myself one
of but I believe it's morally okay to
vote I do believe
and some of them don't and so they would
say well I love Ron Paul but I won't
vote for him and I thought you know he's
an old guy who's busting his rear for
you
make an exception for this guy well I
thought the same thing when I thought
about all these people doing this
thankless drudgery in the libertarian
party getting petitions signed you know
getting signatures for ballot access I
mean this is not fun and it reminded me
of that
the late dr. Feldman who gave that
extraordinary little talk in 2016 at the
convention this Mark Allen film Mark
Allen felt a heat wave sorry and and he
he had this amazing little few minute
thing and and he referred to those get
those petitions signed in the rain
libertarians and I thought you know I am
a libertarian and I believe this stuff
and hear that here are the foot soldiers
who've been doing this thankless work
for years and years I'd like to help
them and I'd also and I guess I'd like
to feel like I'm in a political home
where instead of just having to settle
well this is the best I'll find well but
regardless of what their vote total is
if these are the people who are saying
what you believe why don't you join them
so that was the the motivation behind it
and then I you know I do want to try to
help out the Mises caucus people the
Mises caucus people they basically are
radical libertarians who want to want to
make sure that economics is is a you
know major part of the libertarian
messaging for the reasons I mentioned
earlier that that I think Liberty I
think economics does really ground us it
reminds us about what's fundamental
which is social cooperation on a large
scale also the name Mises they chose
partly because Mises got along well with
anarcho-capitalist like Rothbard even
though Mises was Americus and that's how
they view view themselves they want to
get along with people who might fall
somewhere along that divide and just
work together the best they can and and
and you know and they want to stay they
want to focus on you know that they want
to talk about the central bank issue
because nobody else does and Ron Paul
put that front and center they want to
do that so I'd like to see that I'd like
to see the party become exciting I feel
like especially based on my own
experience the public needs to be jolted
rather than lulled to sleep or comforted
by somebody who seems respectable I'm
not saying you should gratuitously be
not respectable
but I mean we don't necessarily have to
be nominating somebody who comes from
you know a political background
necessarily and in particular I think in
my own experience it wasn't people who
said well Tom you know you might be 12%
mistaken about the it was people who
said look you're dead wrong and you're
looking at this the whole the wrong with
me your instincts are good but you're
not following where they ought to lead
you and that was what what shook me and
I I feel like that probably is what
people I mean for people who we have a
country filled with people who think
John McCain is somebody they want their
children to emulate and I wouldn't want
that those people need to be jolted they
don't need to be patted on the head and
told we just need to cut the capital
gains tax a few points I think there are
a lot of people in the party who are
equally reticent about nominating
another former moderate Republican
Governor after they've done that last
couple of times but they might also
point out that hey last time we tripled
any vote that there has ever been before
there's it's kind of a tangible momentum
of the party right now they have a
hundred and seventy elected officials
they're putting more people candidates
this time around than any midterm ever
like maybe that was a good step there do
you think it was a bad step to have Gary
Johnson as the well I'd rather have Gary
Johnson than bill weld there I said it
the I said the name bill weld and I've I
think Gary Johnson has many fine
qualities and I think it would be a good
thing for him to get elected to the US
Senate although they're trying some
shenanigans to try to stop his momentum
in New Mexico it's true that I mean
lookee there's no arguing with they did
get a lot of votes that's true and I I'm
not sure how much this translates into
party membership and activism because is
this the kind of person you say my life
was changed forever when I encountered
the philosophy of Gary Johnson I don't
think so and I would rather have
somebody who's gonna build the ranks of
the people who will go out and do all
that hard work that needs to be done and
I just I just an
so I want it to be somebody who loves
the ideas who doesn't just feel like
well I'm fiscally responsible so I'm
sort of like a libertarian because I
also favor gay marriage that is so a
caricature of what we are we're not just
drawing arbitrarily from the other two
we have our own we're the most
internally consistent people there are
up there and I want our nominee at least
to be somebody who is well read and well
versed in it and can't wait to get out
there and spread that message instead of
you ask him about a famous libertarian
author and the guy stumbles and I'm not
saying he has to be a PhD in history or
in economics but at least have the
curiosity to be self-taught and be on
fire for it and excited and that four
years after your last campaign you're
much better and more effective cuz
you've been studying and learning and
reading and practising your speaking and
then four years later it turns out
you're the same guy come on you owe the
ideas more than that fact-check I have
met one person of note who is totally
turned into a libertarian because of
Larry Charlotte yeah that's right but he
will tell that story god that's right
Larry sharp is killing me for that but
that's okay as long as it worked I don't
care how it worked
here's a question why not Trump there
are people in your orbit who are more
let's say friendly disposed towards
Trump I wanted an extra ly in there
I will then since we were talking about
Ron Paul before I want to read you an
extended quote from The Washington Post
by your sometimes colleague Lew Rockwell
at the Mises Institute in an article by
Dave waggle about Justin Amash just a
click off as many boxes as possible and
this is pretty interesting I think
Trump's victory Lew Rockwell says
vindicated Ron Paul because Trump used
many of the themes that Ron Paul
stressed throughout his career though
unfortunately Trump did not deploy these
in a consistent way opposition to elite
control calls for a pro-american foreign
policy that avoids intervention and
quarrels that do not concern us
opposition to PC and cultural Marxism
and concerned with the fed manipulation
of the economy as themes are themes
straight out of Ron Paul's playbook do
you agree with that assessment or how
would you differ from that sense
definitely some of it sounds like Ron
Paul but the problem with Trump was he's
the opposite of Ron Paul in his interest
in ideas because what I was just getting
done talking about I mean you know Ron
Paul has read every book there is right
whereas I've heard rumors about the
number of books Donald Trump is right
now again for what he did in the private
sector he probably didn't have to read a
lot of books fair enough
but when you become president and you're
gonna be pushing ideas you got to be
grounded in those ideas so on the one
hand sometimes he could say things about
foreign policy that would make me not an
agreement and then the very next day
would sound like he was saying the
opposite or he would say something about
the Fed oh we know we got a we got to
get more control over the Fed and the
next day he'd say but you know I'm a low
interest rate man but then okay so then
what's the point of getting control over
the fit so that's the problem is that
yeah there I could isolate some parts of
Trump that do sound like Ron Paul but
then I could isolate some parts that
make me completely crazy and and you
know so that's the thing is that because
he's not grounded in it he's he's
flighty in one day's here in one day is
there and what proves this is that you
know remember there was that anonymous
op-ed in The New York Times the other
day about somebody supposedly a senior
official in the administration and I
don't think the New York Times is lying
about that
well senior officials are malleable
that's true that's true but I think it
would hurt them tremendously if it
turned out that it was a guy who was
cleaning the floor or something but when
that when that thing came out it just
was served to remind me that Trump has
surrounded himself through choices made
by himself alone by people who are at
odds with him on his major issues and
that again goes to show he's not even
steeped in who the personnel would be if
he wanted to have a foreign policy like
the one half the time he claimed he
wanted or on economic policy he's got
people in there like Larry Kudlow
I don't think Larry Kudlow has been
against low interest rates pushed by the
Fed I could be wrong about that I don't
think I am so why is he doing that again
it shows that he's a mile wide and an
inch deep and that's the kind that's
precisely the kind of guy who gets
manipulated by the people around him and
if he can't even pick decent people
around him this is gonna end badly so in
your I'm going to pigeonhole your three
issues as being war economics and the
Fed
maybe yeah something like that like that
so how do you evaluate Trump on those
well so far just it's an actual record
in office he's done a lot of bombing but
he hasn't gotten the u.s. into any new
wards so unfortunately by the metric of
the last few presidents that makes him
okay
I was when the serious strike hit I did
an immediate episode on that very
unhappy about that and very creeped out
by the media response that he's finally
presidential Brian Williams I think was
hand over his heart it's just it's so
weird I just don't understand I mean it
really for every once in a while you
think maybe they are lizard people what
other explanation could there be
let's see I'll skip the economy that's
the most the trickiest one but on the
Fed all right well I mean he's
I guess he appointed Jerome Powell but
you know these are basically
establishment picks there's not gonna be
any major change there and and again
Trump has been saying he wants now he's
supposedly there's been talk that he
wants to interfere with the political
independence of the Fed but I think
that's always that independence of the
Fed has been kind of a sham anyway but I
think on the Fed he what signal has he
been sending other than keep the
interest rates we're you know where they
are so that's not you know I'm not good
with grading on an A to F scale but
let's just say he would be getting a
progress report going home and then on
the economy there are some good things
the spending issue is just not he's
apparently just not interested in
cutting spending but I think that was
pretty obvious from his camp he didn't
run on he didn't talk about spent any
certainly didn't talk about the
entitlement because I think he felt like
his base depends on those entitlements
why would I why would it occur to me to
go after those so you I think if anybody
was expecting that they shouldn't have
been so on that he's not very good but
you do hear a lot of behind-the-scenes
talk about deregulation in a lot of
areas so you know that certainly is good
and the number of pages of regulations
that exist seems to have been cut so I
guess I'm in favor of that are you
worried about trade Wars III sort of am
I'm not sure how far he's gonna go with
this or if he really AM it could be that
he genuinely I hate to attribute for DHS
to
because it's it's getting tiresome at
this point oh he actually has a secret
plan all along
oh yeah that's why he surrounded himself
with his own enemies what what kind of
secret plan was that but it could well
be that he's using that in large part as
a bargaining chip and you know and he
knows the dangers that are involved I
don't know but yeah that would be pretty
bad especially because he's making
people think that if we have more taxes
this will make you more prosperous these
are the same conservatives who for years
would tell you that taxes inhibit
prosperity but if it's a sales tax on
imported goods this makes you richer
this is not good to lead people down
this road there's some resistance within
libertarian circles the pragmatist
caucus is kind of at loggerheads with
the Mises caucus or at least was it the
convention people always get very
excited for a half a second and then
move on to whatever the next conflict is
but I reached out to remember the
pragmatist caucus said I'm interviewing
Tom woods what's your question oh good
so buckle up you have a history of
promoting organizations and individuals
like the League of the South Hans
Hermann Hop sorry if I mispronounced
that Hans
Gary North Chris Cantwell and Stefan mul
knew that a lot of libertarians regard
as anti libertarian and bigoted why
should the party which has achieved its
peak success under leaders like Nicholas
our work and Gary Johnson ditched them
in order to follow your lead before you
answer if there's anything that's
specifically inaccurate about that you
want to address before getting into a
broader thing yeah no well I'll do that
as I do it I mean I wouldn't quite say
this is it's true that I have a
so-called promoted a lot of those I've
had a lot of different people from a lot
of different backgrounds on my show I've
done as of this recording you know well
over 1200 episodes that's crazy yeah
it's yeah sure no I should be in an
insane asylum as sometimes I look around
the world I feel like I already am but
alright so yeah I might as well come out
just address this when I told you about
being a moderate Republican in like 1990
that is where I started that's where my
dad who was a blue-collar worker that's
what he got me to he got me to see the
problems with communism and whatever I
thought well I got to be a Republican
for sure and then after that I dabbled a
little bit
libertarianism for a couple years I went
to IH Institute for Humane studies
seminars I went to the Mises university
program and then for probably seven
years I was more in the paleo
conservative camp so I did I did
actually believe in heaven help me
protectionism I have a piece I wrote
that I'm embarrassed about where I'm
clearly indicating that protectionism
will make workers wealthier I'm sorry I
was wrong about that there are a lot of
things from that up in those years that
I look back on and say ah China I didn't
I wouldn't say in fact all through the
1990s if you looked through anything I
wrote at no time do I refer to myself as
a libertarian I liked a lot of
libertarians I was friendly with them
but I thought they're just their heads
are in the clouds I mean the sort of
thing people say about libertarians now
that's what I believed at that time so
yeah you can dig through I wrote an
article in an academic journal about
capitalism that I'm not proud of so yeah
you can the problem with capitalism well
I was taking the right-wing
traditionalist argument against
capitalism that had up roots people all
right you know that sort of thing and so
I look back on that and these are the
very kinds of things that make me crazy
today most of the time not all the time
but most of the time when people are
going back and say well look at what
wood said it's always it from the 1990s
yeah I know before I was a libertarian
Matt I was a terrible libertarian now if
the whole league of the South thing has
blown up because of what's gone on
recently the story they're on I'll just
tell it very quickly but I have to go to
Tom woods calm you type in League south
into the search bar I'm talking about
the story 1994 I was in my senior year
of college and my old friend Jeff Tucker
called me up and said there's a meeting
of academics going on in Tuscaloosa
where they want to talk about radical
decentralization and even secession and
of course that I did favor as a paleo
con in those days because and as a
libertarian I also favor radical
decentralization but I thought that's
the way you strike at the US Empire you
break it into pieces
so I said yeah yeah sure let's go and
one of the people there was Forrest
McDonald who was a professor at the
University of Alabama at the time
Forrest McDonald was
held the position of Jefferson lecturer
of the National Endowment for the
Humanities that is the highest honor in
the humanities the US government bestows
so a young historian like me going to a
meeting with Forrest McDonald well who
wouldn't write me as far as me nobody
thinks Forrest McDonald is a white
supremacist or in fact when he died I
forget how many years ago the New York
Times didn't even mention this because
they all know it's Forrest McDonald so
we went and my view was this group
should not be a southern group I said we
should have a group that favors D
central is if Hawaii wants
decentralization let's do that anywhere
in the country where people are
interested in it but most people voted
that it should be a southern
organization because the South has a
history of decentralization so alright
well that's better than nothing so I
said okay because I had not lived in the
south of that planet lived I grew up in
Massachusetts I went to got my PhD in
New York but I thought well I had just
taken American intellectual history with
a guy named Donald Fleming and Fleming
had us read I'll take my stand which is
the book by the so called twelve
southerners where they talked about
valuable things about the Southern
tradition
none of which involved slavery obviously
and I read that thinking she's I had
always thought the South was just you
know stupid ignorant rednecks and then I
read this thing and I thought whoa okay
there is something valuable worth
preserving here I'm sure people will
understand this is my motivation that's
not the case so in the early days of the
organization there was nothing wrong
with it I know there are some people who
will say if it's a southern organization
it must be wicked that is not true they
were entirely mainstream people there
Eugene Genovese they called Clyde Wilson
one of the top ten southern historians
of our age and he was there I mean what
he gonna say what Clyde Wilson we're not
allowed to talk to so it was it was
basically academics Donald Livingston
was there he's probably the greatest
living David Hume scholar so that
basically it was a dorky organization of
PhDs but now in recent years it's become
something rather different and the the
president of the organization who is the
same recently admitted this and it in a
way it helps me that he's being honest
about it that he said you know some
people say I've taken the league in a
whole new radical new
rection well you're darn right I have
and then he lists you know now we're
gonna do this and this and this and
we're gonna invite this person in that
person and the thing is now it reflects
on everybody who was ever associated I
mean anybody who knows me or my persona
or has listened to many for me for any
length of time knows that I wouldn't be
involved in something sinister but the
problem is I will not apologize because
the group I joined was a bunch of nerdy
academics like me and there's nothing
wrong with that group that I joined so
I'm not going to apologize for that and
I could save myself an enormous amount
of grief if I would just say to you Matt
Welch I did the wrong thing and I'll
never do it again I will not apologize
because I am sick and tired of cowards
who get cornered who say oh I'm so sorry
I did or said the wrong thing I'm not
gonna be part of that and even though
that means I got to carry this with me
to my grave I'm not doing it I will not
back down on that but so now I realize
what that means is I have to go around
correcting people saying well there's a
more nuance to the store
it's hopeless it's one of these things
where where there is no solution there
is no problem there's nothing I can do
about this at this point other than
assume that people of goodwill who know
me will say all right I'm I'm sure
that's the situation you know I mean
that can't be right now the rest of
these people that they mentioned I mean
you know I don't know if we want to
spend all this time going through each
and every one of now but but the point
is yeah okay I think I mean that there's
a broader question here there's a
there's a or let's say category of
critique right of people which is that
it's kind of is there an alt right
pipeline to libertarianism and is Mises
broadly part of that pipeline so address
that yeah sure sure if you think that's
a thing and is it a problem first of
okay first of all let me just note that
if you look at Tom woods come slash
episodes and you look down that list it
is a wide wide broad array of people
from all over the libertarian movement
because I'm friendly with almost
everybody there are some people who kind
of have it out for me but but there and
the things they say my listeners say
what who could they be listening to that
they say I don't think they do listen to
me that's the thing I think the less
people listen to me them the more they
dislike me that I I so that's a problem
but this alt-right pipeline
thing I used to say there's no such
thing as an alt right pipeline from
libertarianism to the alright if that's
what you mean I used to think that there
is no such thing now I think okay
alright I think there probably is to
some degree there has been I remember in
my Facebook feed
there was look to me like also a
libertarian pipeline to Bernie Sanders I
had a lot of people in my feed who
suddenly loved Bernie Sanders and I
thought how could you like Bernie
Sanders and also have been for Ron Paul
and I think it was just the
anti-establishment thing and so that
anti-establishment thing can take you to
Ron Paul Bernie Sanders Donald Trump and
maybe even the alt-right
so there is that strain in libertarian
me because let's face it we're not the
establishment and so we we carry just
inherently an anti-establishment strain
so I think that that that could well be
the case but the question would be how
extensive is it and does it really
matter I mean you look at when we had
the Charlottesville event in 2017 we had
a lot of people very very concerned
about this growing movement and then the
and and whereas my view was this is not
a big issue I don't think there are that
many people involved and the people who
are involved have zero influence
anywhere and if if word comes out that
they're involved their careers are
destroyed I'm not worried about those
people I think we're overreacting
and I think this year 2018 when they
tried to do Charlottesville part two and
it was what a couple of dozen people and
a thousand protesters I mean I think
that vindicates my point that we're
getting much too worked up about a
problem that I think is gonna resolve
itself and fizzle out so if there is a
libertarian - all right pipeline if it's
a group that is barely I mean these days
it's hard to see what content they're
producing does it even matter anymore I
don't I don't think they were presents
now I could be wrong maybe they're gonna
have a big revival in two years I don't
see where that's coming from you talk
about being a paleo conservative there's
kind of an overlap to a paleo
libertarian strategy that was associated
with Murray Rothbard and through
Rockwell on other and maybe not many
others looking back
were their errors there that was that a
good strategy on their part how do you
assess that period your involvement with
it or not but just you know looking back
at it was that a good thing well I was
very young in those days but I did go to
the John Randolph Club a couple of times
and I loved it the John Randolph club
was an organization that I don't exactly
know who the founders were but rothbard
must have had a hand in it the idea was
they're gonna take libertarians like
rothbard and then they were gonna take
some of the Paleo cons like a chronicles
magazines like Tom Fleming and Clyde
Wilson and Paul Godfrey and they were
all gonna meet and exchange ideas and
say that now the Cold War is over a
major division point between us has gone
away and these were conservatives who
said now the Cold War is over we can go
back to being a normal country and they
were shocked at how many conservatives
were saying well we have 28 other
enemies we want to use this military on
so rothbard had said since 1956 and I
found a private letter of his where he
says I'm coming to believe that the war
peace issue is the issue of the whole
libertarian business so he'd believed
that for 40 you know 35 years at that
point so I so anyway so I went to these
meeting and they were just a blast they
were so much fun that's where I met Bill
Kauffman who I think has written for
reason and the rest was an employer firm
oh that's her and he worked for reason
and Bill is uncatted ERISA belittling I
don't know what he is or how he
describes himself but I react off
monologist yeah right
but Kaufman I mean he was the sort of
guy I would never have met otherwise
because he wouldn't go to a libertarian
conference but he'd come to this and I I
know that the easiest thing in the world
to say is well this was a bad decision
and that's this shouldn't have been done
but I think Paul Godfried is brilliant I
mean he is a absolutely amazing European
intellectual historian Clyde Wilson is
one of the best southern historians
you'll ever find he was the editor of
the Calhoun papers which is a big
scholarly project that's a big deal
Tom Fleming and I had a bit of a falling
out years later but I still think he's I
think he's a genius I think he writes so
I wish I could write like Tom Fleming
and I look back on these folks and I say
no I'm glad I met them and
remember this the internet was bit like
we had email but we didn't really have
the Internet in those days and in those
days as in Rothbart's day in the 1960s
when he felt he had to have an alliance
with the left well we don't really need
alliances so much anymore because you
don't have to think to yourself well
it's really expensive to put out a
magazine so I better have an alliance
with the people who have that magazine
so I can get published there and we can
work together anybody can start a
website now and so we don't have to have
a lie it's not as a urgent that we have
alliances so-called but Rothbard in the
60s felt like he had to reach out to the
left again mostly over the war issue
because he was not comfortable with
National Review well likewise he's not
comfortable with a lot of people in the
early 90s and he thinks war is for me
the key thing let's reach out to these
people I don't I I don't think that's
bad the fact that he found other non
interventionist I support that I think
that's a good thing this cultural
smashmouth going along with it though I
mean it's it felt like at that time
reading through some of the papers and
documentation it's hey we can we can get
these people if we appeal to their sense
of you know runaway criminality among
certain classes of people like that it
that didn't seem as nice and interesting
as hey let's let's bond over war in
general I would say the overwhelming
amount of stuff that came out of that
was on a very high academic level like
if you looked at what Chronicles
magazine was writing in those days
Chronicles magazine is what made me
anti-war and they were they were
old-fashioned traditional conservatives
and they were conservatives who would be
a little bit sometimes they could be
anti-capitalist for the reasons that I
gave either you know they want the
mom-and-pop shop rather than the big-box
store and things like that and the
thinking was the libertarians will try
to educate them on economics and then
maybe they can educate us on whatever it
could be history or what whatever
intellectual history and what I think
happened was the libertarians really did
try to learn things but the Palio's just
stayed with their same economics like
almost none of them budged so I think
rothbard started to throw his hands up
in despair after a while that we've kind
of kept up our end of the bargain you're
not you're really not gonna learn any
economics after all the effort we put
into this so I think that's where but
that's mostly what it was was
mostly talking about that stuff trying
to teach each other this is what we know
that you don't know and and she's if
Rothbart's teaching economics and you're
still not getting it yeah okay I think
we've done what we can do here you
mentioned that you can just start your
own damn things now you've had your
podcasts and for five years yeah now
tell us a little bit what what were you
thinking when you started and what have
you learned
oh she's my used to be a fill-in host
when Peter Schiff had an actual
terrestrial radio show and I would
actually go down to a radio station in
my town and I would host for him and it
was a blast I just love doing I took
calls and it was great and I have a ton
of people who say that's how I
discovered you I listen to Peter Schiff
and then you were guest hosting and so
then I decided to do you know like my
own spin-off you know I would be the
Jeffersons to his all in the family or
whatever I was gonna be the spin-off so
I came up with you know that the Tom
Woods show and at first I thought it
would be live and I would take calls and
I hate calls you know I don't I don't
hate call I just I don't like listening
to shows where people take cuz sometimes
the caller goes on forever and it's not
interesting so but I thought I'd like to
be that guy who somehow produces
something every single day every single
every single weekday at least and this
was at a time when I was engaged in the
most time-consuming project I have ever
done which was I created 400 videos on
history for the Ron Paul home school
program and that took me two years it
was it's an absurd project I don't know
I must have been crazy to take it on but
I I thought in order to do this project
I'm gonna have to retreat from you know
public life as it were today you know to
the extent that I was in it because I'm
so busy I need to produce something
finite not that long and doable every
day so that people don't forget about me
while I'm in hibernation doing this
project so that was the odd thing was I
started the prot the podcast because I
was so overwhelmingly busy but I felt
like maybe this will be something that
keeps my name out there every single day
and so I've just kept it up and kept it
up and somehow here we are at episode
1200 and whatever
and then Bob Murphy my friend Bob Murphy
and I we do a once a week podcast called
contra krugman we take Paul Krugman's
New York Times column and we critique it
and once in a while he's right and we're
honest enough to admit that and what I
love about Bob is that he will bend over
backwards to try to find a way to show
that his opponent may be saying
something sensible he's not looking to
beat down strong men and we never on the
podcast say Paul Krugman's a stupid
idiot that's what a lot of people say in
our Facebook threads but we actually
don't say that because he's not a stupid
idiot he's wrong but he's not a stupid
idiot and and I'm really proud of that
podcast too because Bob and I have this
excellent banter and he makes fun of me
because I don't have a degree in
economics my degrees in history and we
just have fun doing it but we're
teaching a lot of really good economics
week in and week out and we never run
out of material because Krugman is our
weekly foil and that's been tremendous
we do an annual cruise based around that
podcast called the Contra cruise so it's
with the podcast as this at the center
I've had a lot of things that kind of
revolve around it that make it you know
that allow me to have a nice comfortable
life so we wrote a book called meltdown
we're on what year nine of largely tepid
but recently a little bit more heated
recovery and I want to over characterize
and say that that Austrian economic
school people are a little bit more
Irish
catice apocalyptic yeah then than some
of their friends associated with Chicago
School so tell us are we going to be
eating cat food soon no I don't think so
but I will say on that apocalyptic thing
that a lot of times it tends to be
investment newsletter people rather than
the academics who are actually working
over thin the Austrian school because
III I'm across very few of them who go
around saying hyperinflations around the
corner I don't think people should be
predicting hyperinflation I don't think
that my very worst reason cover in my
tenure as editor there with inflation
returns which I think I've put in 2009
well it's not to say we would it's never
going to come back but I don't think
it's going to be buy more Germany
certainly but
it's well given that fundamentals of
economic policy have not changed you
know that I do think there will be you
know obviously there's gonna be a
correction we all know that I don't know
when that's gonna be
but then side by side with the
correction there's the fiscal issue
looming of course related to the you
know the entitlement problem which is a
really really extreme time bomb I mean
if you've heard I'm sure that you know
the Laurence Kotlikoff estimates of in
excess of two hundred trillion dollars
in the whole I mean that I'm actually
more concerned about than another
recession because that's gonna win a
recession you come out of eventually but
this if that's really true he's right
these programs are that underfunded
you're talking about wrenching social
changes that almost nobody is prepared
for yeah we I think are just you know
six to ten years out from having to give
people a 25% haircut on Social Security
just kind of as a opening opening bid is
there it is so is the libertarian party
the vehicle for for beginning to address
this or one of several because it really
seems like the two major parties have
stopped all even rhetorical noise in
that direction then that that's why the
libertarian party has to do it even
though again it's not going to win them
popularity contests but given that
they're probably not going to get the
seventy million votes at least they can
be a channel of information to
responsible people around the country
saying isn't it interesting that neither
one of these people will say a word
about this time bomb how can you trust
them I mean I've sometimes thought that
the lp should I mean when you appeal to
the young the problem is that young just
don't vote they for whatever reason they
don't vote the way the older folks do
but the fact is the interest in
libertarianism is so much greater among
the young than it is among the old that
I thought they should have an ad where
you know two to oldsters you know pull
up in in Buicks and you know one's a red
Buick and one's a blue Buick and they
represent the old parties and then you
have some you know you know people young
people in a sports car going by you know
and and and I would have I would start
off by saying remember how there used to
be three television stations and you
know two major you know outlets for news
and this is no they don't really I know
exactly what this is what you say is in
your pair
day they had this this this and they
also had two political party so you make
it seem like that's just so silly and
backward that's what my mom and dad did
I got to break free out of that miss
something something to appeal to their
natural teenage rebellious
so in closing are you optimistic or
pessimistic in this moment it's a very
strange political moment that we live in
governance moment parties the two major
parties seem to be just kind of ripped
up and read morphing and both of them
kind of our victim of a semi off hostile
takeover at least Bernie Sanders didn't
quite win but the heart of the
Democratic Party seems heading in that
direction
that can be seen as like a really
interesting revolutionary ferment it can
also be seen like my god it's all coming
down apart around us and people don't
behave very well when things are in that
type of crisis what is your that's
producer I did just see a statistic
saying when they asked Democrats would
you like to see that the Democratic
Party go more in the direction of Barack
Obama or Bernie Sanders and it was 69 28
Obama but I think there is just
nostalgia more you know for a president
that they they trusted and liked by and
large so because I think that is a bit
of a misleading number because I do
think this democratic socialist movement
is just starting to gain steam yeah I I
have the same concerns you have that
it's and also the country is I know it's
a silly cliche to say the country is
divided but my gosh it's like a burning
hatred that a lot of people have for a
lot of other people and it's in its
mutual it's a burning hatred that when I
asked growth you know when I was growing
up in the 80s and then going to grad
school in the 90s I don't remember that
I mean we argued but I don't remember it
being you know I hope I mean let's just
the other day there was an event I guess
a few months ago Jordan Peterson had an
event at Queen's University in Canada
and there are people on the outside of
that building who'd been removed for
disruption and they're piling on the the
doors and windows and they're saying
lock them in and burn it down now I
don't remember that happening when I was
growing up I certainly aren't the
psychology professors you have right to
set of all possible people right I mean
mild mannered psycho so that does
concern me but the thing that makes me
happy
and that makes me feel good about this
situation is you have to remember and
it's important for young people who grew
up with the Internet to remember this
that we live in a world now where with a
couple of I'll grant you major
exceptions in almost any part of the
world you can get access to almost any
book you might want instantly
downloadable you know man we're moving
to a point where more and more books
will be available like that the spread
of ideas I mean could you imagine our
ancestors in this movement being a
situation where they could distribute
their propaganda in a good sense of that
word to anybody who might be interested
in consuming the nerve center was within
walking distance from here it was lazy
Fair books you know that's right they
you needed that bookstore to be right I
used to order from less a fair books
yeah
and I and I would order by writing them
a check and putting it in the mail and
it was just luck it was just fortuitous
that I happened upon less a fair books
whereas now I mean the fact that the
fact that Reason magazine has this
reason TV or that I'm just some guy who
wrote some books and people liked them
so I have a show where in principle in
fact I look at the statistics of all the
countries where a substantial number
people listen this is a miracle and I
know it's disappointing that a lot of
people in this situation just want to
watch cat videos alright but that's
probably gonna be the case no matter
what the state of Technology is but
there are a lot of Minds out there that
are going to be exposed to the most
liberating set of ideas ever thanks to
this and so that makes me think well if
we still lose even after that we can at
least say we gave it the old college try
but we've you know we've got a fighting
shot for once in our lives on that
optimistic note thank you very much Tom
woods it's the Tom woods podcast the
Contra Krugman not Krugman but Krugman
podcast thank you very much for joining
us thank you man
you